hi I'm Ryan Wright today we're gonna be
watching the trailer for Batman Arkham
Knight officer down
gameplay trailer well away what you need
Tyrone Magnus already did one with a
Batman mask now [ __ ] tie whatever
you're all gonna have to deal with my
hat here now anyway yeah we're gonna be
watching the officer down gameplay
trailer there's been so many cinematic
trailers I hate sorry I've gotta go
Barbara you still know how to make an
entrance
any lead on scarecrow we were tracking
an unknown military vehicle speeding
through Chinatown it's the only lead
we've had all night but they gave us the
slip
if you find it tell your men not to
engage I'll deal with it do you really
think scarecrows crazy enough to
detonate a chemical weapon and Gotham I
won't let that happen Jim he's on it
Oracle I need the location of unit 247
he's holding up she looks really happy
[ __ ] Batman do you know how awesome
is this
Wow [ __ ] details man
beer multi tape
this is what the movies gotta [ __ ] be
like this kind of martial arts Wow how
are these people not dead
ouch
I can use them healthier
oh he's gonna take his time you're safe
I thought they were
the city's overrun we don't stand a
chance
stay here I'll send someone to pick you
up what are you doing
evening the odds
even the odds
so here it's like beautiful it's it's
beautiful look at how beautiful it is
this much beautiful man
god damn it Mike
six this is Commissioner forth
firing guns at someone
like there's people in that bank right
hey get stuff out of this bad movie
I like one bad man it's anxious time
that's when it's cool
Gidi kind of totally murdered that guy
where is he every bone in your body okay
if you lie I'll break the other one
you're a liar oh [ __ ]
he did his Christian Bale and Bryan
Cranston Oracle check the chemical
analysis like just uploaded sure
scarecrows new toxin an uncontaminated
sample and I have home would be more
subtle scared boys at the safe house
nearby
did if you like wanna be an aunt like
this
nothin's worse it's beautiful
okay look here's what I gotta say hey I
know my hair looks weird right now B
I've said a lot of things about this
game already and when we're viewing
these trailers and here's only the only
thing I'm going to talk about you have
to play this game at least once and you
know not even once but like play to the
point where you really feel like you got
the controller's down because part of
the great gameplay experience is living
vicariously through a character and
getting to experience these things when
you get lost in the game it sounds
cheesy it sounds silly but it's true
like you get lost in it and if you want
to feel like you're Batman and you want
to feel like you're in Gotham City you
can only feel that way when you really
feel like you got the controls down so
wait till you got the controls down and
then the game just becomes so much more
fun that way I want to play just for
that reason alone is because how many
times did we watch superheroes and go I
all want to know what it's like to be a
superhero or you want to feel like a
superhero like this is the best way to
do it is a really good video game that
can make you a part of it that is so
[ __ ] awesome just look at the details
of Gotham and then the details of the
gameplay and the cinematics like it's
all like there's so many options of what
you could do as Batman it's [ __ ]
awesome
like there's more freedom to being the
bat than ever I'm so [ __ ] stoked for
this game if you guys are new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter and we have a vine
too and we're working on a pornhub.com
account at least I have